moi ça me fait pas peur de recevoir de
l'amour c'est plutôt de recevoir le
nombre de la moi ce que les gens ne se
donne pas vraiment ils font semblant de
se donner la plupart du temps où il
donne la partie qui qu'ils ont besoin de
données pour un réconfort personnel il
ya des gens qui vont se donner juste
pour combler un manque
parce qu'ils ont envie qu'on les aime
avec passion la même façon pour moi
c'est pas ça la mort l'amour ccsa
proposé à l'autre
[Musique]
je connais de l'avion des glaces et que
je pense qu'elle est moche mais ce qui
est bien dans la vie ce sont des bons
moments moi c'est ma vision
je pense pas les romans en aura toujours
mais ça je pense que ce qui est
important c'est le bon moment la vie
actuellement les moches que tu le
veuilles ou non si tu as travaillé de
lever tôt c'est la merde mais quand il
passe un bon moment
[Musique]
oui
et
je pars avec des mots en fait c'est
comme si quand je construis mon morceau
cc c'est des phrases qui expriment des
situations plein de trucs et à la fin de
si tu peux pas l'écouter son recul en
fait
[Musique]
m
quand tu vois où une personne qui chante
un sens que tu as écrit dans les
chiottes
c'est parce que c'est mon endroit
hâtivement c'est fascinant c'est
bluffant c'est surprenant c
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
ici les gens sont plus xénophobes que
raciste aux etats unis les gens sont
racistes
c'est une différence énorme parce que
ici c'est plus de la peur tandis que là
c'est de la haine
aux etats unis c'est aussi simple que ça
s'est desserré c'est la bêtise tu crois
que c'est des gens qui n'ont pas envie
de réfléchir c'est de la bêtise et de la
fainéantise parce que t'as pas envie
d'aller vers l'autre t'as pas envie de
découvrir l'autre parce que tu penses
que ce que tu es et mieux que ce que
notre ère c'est la petite reine en fait
tu peux toujours apprendre de quelqu'un
n'importe qui même quelqu'un qui parle
pas la langue dans le cas partir de ce
moment là je pense que c'est de la
bêtise ne peut pas essayer de combat je
peux pas essayer de comprendre à à ce
poste lui même ne se comprend même pas
[Musique]
mais comment
j'ai beaucoup d'ambition et
je pense que quand il va changer
beaucoup de choses une étagère partir tu
joues tu es toi-même en fait donc je
n'aurai pas très long je me vois pas
dans 50 ans